[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt
heute gibt Pasta Schiff nämlich aus
übrig gebliebene Nudeln könnt ihr ganz
tollen Resteverwertung machen oder für
dieses Rezept extra Nudeln abkochen ich
hab hier also kalte Nudeln und die
werden gleich mariniert und dann im Ofen
gegart und dann hat man ihn richtig toll
leckeren Snack der ist im Prinzip wie
Chips und ich habe mir da jetzt drei
Geschmacksrichtungen dazu überlegt ich
habe den Passat Trend auf tik tok
entdeckt und habe mir gedacht komm wir
machen da jetzt direkt drei verschiedene
Version draus ich habe mir sogar sechs
Rezepte überlegt aber können wir uns mal
nicht übertreiben wir machen drei ich
habe einmal die Version cheese Oregano
ich habe eine Döner Version und eine
honey mustard so bisschen wie diese
Snyder pretzels da gibt's Erotik
Geschmacksrichtung ich habe mir noch
drei weitere überlegt also wenn ihr
wollt dass ich die drei weiteren auch
noch mache dann schreibst einfach gerne
in die Kommentare ansonsten starte ich
jetzt mal mit cheese Oregano ich habe
jetzt hier einfach immer 225g rohrnudel
abgekocht abkühlen lassen und es sind
sie jetzt praktisch und wie gesagt ihr
könnt auch einfach die Nudelreste dafür
verwenden die sind jetzt schon kalt hier
sind die Zutaten ich verwende dafür
Olivenöl fünf Esslöffel 100 Gramm
Parmesan den habe ich schon fein
gerieben Salz und Pfeffer und 1
Esslöffel Oregano
und ja Zubereitung ist ganz easy einfach
kurz alles verrühren das heißt alles
schön mit dem Öl bedecken
Gewürze rein verrühren und ab aufs Blech
[Musik]
das reicht jetzt schon wahnsinnig gut
und dann kannst du ja direkt auf Blech
ich werde aber gleich alle drei zusammen
backen den Ofen habe ich schon
vorgeheizt auf 180 Grad Heißluft dann
kann ich nämlich drei Bleche
gleichzeitig backen hier ist einfach
drauf achten dass alles ein bisschen
Einzel darlegen damit sie auch rundherum
schön kross werden
und Sally was hast du heute so gemacht
ich habe Nudeln sortiert auf dem Blech
echt den ganzen Tag
[Musik]
version1 ist fertig jetzt kommt die
zweite nämlich die Döner Version für die
Döner Version verwende ich Chili
Olivenöl davon fünf Esslöffel dann habe
ich hier noch die Gewürze Salz und
Pfeffer etwas Kreuzkümmel
bergbohnenkraut und Paprika
[Musik]
die Chili Version am besten mit Löffeln
verrühren denn sonst verfärben sich eure
Hände und Nägel und vor allem Chili an
den Fingern ist immer gefährlich weil
man sich danach bestimmt irgendwie auch
nach dem Händewaschen ins Auge fasst und
dann brennt alles
ja
[Musik]
falls nicht ganz so scharf haben wollt
könnt ihr natürlich auch nur einen
Esslöffel Chiliöl nehmen oder eben
Chilipulver und den Rest mit normalem
Olivenöl
auffüllen aber ich dachte mir so Döner
einmal mit alles und scharf mit hat
jetzt extra scharf
habe ich heute einfach gleich im Ofen
wenn sie so ein bisschen gebacken sind
einmal durch ich sortiert nicht alle
Nudeln
nein auch eine Sally macht das nicht
kommen wir zum dritten Geschmack zur
dritten Geschmacksrichtung nämlich honey
mustard für die honey mustard mir schon
nehme ich Olivenöl fünf Esslöffel dann
habe ich ihr etwas Senf zwei Esslöffel 2
Esslöffel Honig 1 Esslöffel Essig Salz
Pfeffer etwas Kurkuma und Paprikapulver
[Musik]
bei dieser Version für ruhig jetzt kurz
alle Zutaten zu einer Marinade und
vermengt dann mit den Nudeln
[Musik]
ich bin dem Portier wann verfallen
habe ich dir das mal erzählt mit den
Nudeln
mal in der Stadt als Plakataktion waren
ja da stand also ich bin dir so verfalle
Willst du mit mir Penne
lauter so müde nudelnamen ich weiß jetzt
nicht mehr auf
seine Restaurant war in Karlsruhe oder
ob sie mir so Barilla Aktion oder so war
keine Ahnung aber voll lustig
[Musik]
jetzt sind die Pasta Chips fertig ich
habe jetzt hier noch für die cheese
Oregano Version Einsatze Beli gemacht
ist einfach so eine Tomatensoße mit
bisschen Gewürzen hierfür die Kebab
Style eine klar dönersoße oder
Joghurtsoße und für honey mustard habe
ich hier die Cheeseburger Sauce bzw die
Big Mac Soße die findet ihr auf einen
Kanal ich schreibe ich auch alle Rezepte
direkt in in die app und in den Block
jetzt darf der Josch probieren
ich bin
gespannt
es hat vorhin schon so krass gut
gerochen
ich weiß gar nicht was jetzt
ausprobieren will ich glaube Döner Style
muss ehrlich sagen
[Musik]
vergesst ships vergesst Popcorn Pasta
Hammer
[Musik]
Döner Harley Master Döner
lecker
0 2 Minuten
25 Minuten
länger lassen
[Musik]
voll gut
wir
haben
[Musik]
eure lieblings
Geschmacksrichtung in die Kommentare und
kommentiert
[Gelächter]
wollte ich nur sagen falls sie
mobilisiert
[Musik]